this is the 12th in my 10 shorts video
sequence I'm now out of vu footage and I
thought I would do something a bit
different now that I've gathered some
questions and comments mine from my
YouTube viewers and subscribers Facebook
followers Twitter followers Google+
followers all that that social media
stuff and you notice that I'm playing
around with some of the photobooth
settings and using a backdrop from the
School of Athens painting and I thought
that would be kind of apt because these
are all questions that pertain to
philosophy I've had to take some of them
and break them up into into smaller
groups of questions remember that when
when I'm soliciting these these are
supposed to be for two-minute clips so I
can't solve all the are you going to
take a stab at solving the mysteries of
the universe or talk about huge big
picture vast topics in 2 minutes or less
but I can say something about them so I
had to take some of these and and break
them down into simpler phrased or parsed
out questions some of them I had to some
of the questions that were asked were
actually complex questions or whole sets
of questions that I had to break into
separate questions so here you go this
is the first of the the new installment
and we'll see if it provokes any
interesting discussion or or follow-up
so the fates have warned asks me what
are my views on de ontological moral
theories in part because I talked in
previous videos about hedonism
utilitarianism a few other things
including virtue ethics but not much
about de ontology so first let's let's
get clear about what bundles all of
these theories together in terms of de
ontological moral theories and among
them is the conception of duty so with
the day on that which is do that which
one ought to and duty takes precedence
over other considerations such as
character and virtue ethics or you know
the balance of pleasures and pains in
hedonism or in the more refined version
of it that we call utilitarianism over
one's own interests as an egoism and
Duty is is that that central conception
and we could you could set a number of
different thinkers and sub theories with
it within that framework so you've got
usually when we think of the ontology
the people that would come to mind are
Immanuel Kant and you can also see a
stoicism as falling under deontological
ethics W D Ross is clearly as well as
being an intuitionist add a ontology
now what is what is my take on it I
teach these in my ethics classes in part
because there's features of them that I
like quite a bit and I don't see I don't
see moral theories as totally separate
hermetic compartments from each other so
that like either your utilitarian or
your de intelligence or your virtue
ethicists i am a virtue ethicist myself
but that means actually taking on the
better parts of these theories I think
there's a lot to de ontology that I like
I you know I particularly like the
rigour of Kant's ethics although I
disagree with them on many things I like
the emphasis on development that you
find in stoicism and I like Ross's
conception of prima facia duties
so this is a question from Gerald sword
and he's asking me about the merits and
demerits that I see to logical
positivism so this is taking us a good
ways back in time because that that
movement really lost any sort of impetus
that it had in in philosophy in largely
an anglo-american philosophy decades ago
it's still stuff that we we teach
because there's some interesting
features about it and I guess this would
be talking about some of the the merits
of it it's good I think to to ask in a
lot of cases what would count as
verification or falsification for
certain claims I think that they I think
that in trying to say it would always
reduce to something that would be
empirical and usually that could be
scientifically verified that that was a
big mistake on their part and a
confusion of different kinds of forms of
knowledge propositions that this sort of
thing different different you can't
apply the same methodology to everything
and that that's one of the mistakes that
they they made I think that in trying to
make philosophy into the handmaid of
science or into science Sciences you
know sort of slightly slower less
productive step brother or sister that
was a big mistake as well but you know
around the turn of the century after
having like thrown away the entire
history of philosophy except for a
little bits and pieces of it it's easy
to see why they why they would be so
attracted to that conception of doing
philosophy you know who are we thinking
about with this you know air and Carnap
and the younger of it can Stein all fit
into that I don't know for me it's kind
of a dead topic I think that a lot of
people still talk quite a bit about it
but it's it's it's time has long passed
so question from fruit bowl if acacia
nur which is quite a moniker there what
do I think of post-structuralism
or post-modernism in general and I got
to talk about this in less than two
minutes in general I would say that
you've got a bunch of theories and
theorists there that are well worth
reading and thinking about but you've
also got a lot of silliness things that
are quite dated that are just not going
to to stand up and there's a lot of sort
of you need to read this person order to
understand this person to understand
this person and learn this terminology
and although I used to be somebody quite
quite immersed in that I think that
looking at it in in retrospect that
there's kind of a faddish Ness and kind
of a that's kind of you know downright
silliness - - quite a bit of it I think
that a lot of people thought that by
doing theory they were they were
changing things in important ways there
are I would say a lot of people who fit
into that kind of movement or
classification who are well worth
reading and thinking about I
particularly interested in in Jacque
would calm but the Jacque Lacan was
particularly interested in actually
making people better so there had to be
some sort of connection to to the real
whether it's the real that way we
understand it of the real and laconian
sense I also really like George but I I
think his work is kind of interesting
I'm not so big on some of the people
that like Derrida or Toulouse leotard I
find a bit more interesting Foucault I
find I find more interesting but I think
he's wrong headed on a lot of things and
sort of biased and and and stuck in his
own assumptions so that there's are two
minutes
so another question because this is a
complex question asked by fruit
coalification er what is my take on
under EDA or what do I think about d
Reidel yeah and I actually was so
interested in dairy doubt that at one
point I considered writing my
dissertation on on him I didn't end up
doing that I ended up switching to Hegel
and then to Reese blow him down here's
here's my take and this is completely my
own take and there's probably a lot of
people who are better you know versed in
dairy dot who are gonna disagree with
this or find fault with it so I think
that deer he does really works and by
that I mean things like on granite ology
and writing indifference I think those
are brilliant and that they're very
rigorous and they push philosophy
forward and then I thought I think he
lost his way I think that he succumbed
to the the the problem of sort of
believing the his own hype there was a
lot of there was a lot of parts to
deconstruction that we're really just
you know when you when you push the
envelope sometimes you find there's
nothing beyond it and I think that
deconstruction is useful as a is a tool
but I don't think that you can actually
get an entire worthwhile philosophy out
of it and I think that in his middle
period that's part of what happened then
you see him turning back to talking
about you know themes like politics and
and religion and there he starts to get
a bit more traction because those are
real things yeah those are those are
things where it's not just the text and
and endless you know interpretation and
and questioning and although this the
sort of stuff like like you see with
clock you know in the middle period and
I think that stuff is valuable that it's
still marred
so this is a question also by Gerald
sort it was part of his compound
question that he was asking what is the
contemporary trend in epistemology
postpositivism so that's that's not an
easy question to answer in the singular
because there wasn't one trend
postpositivism in part because the pista
mala G is not something that Anglo
American philosophers working in the
analytic tradition had a lock on there
were many other people working in you
know theory of knowledge or chemistry
in osceola G in France and Italy and
Germany and so you could you could you
know if you think about the different
philosophical movements that were out
there and you asked which ones were
particularly interested in
epistemological questions and topics
that would that would kind of fill it in
so in anglo-american philosophy you had
a lot of people interested in in
linguistic analysis for quite a while or
in then you know it took a turn towards
the the question of knowledge is
justified true belief and that seems to
be where a lot of it still circles
they've invented in anglo-american
analytic epistemology they have invented
a lot of terminology which is like its
own form of scholasticism but you know a
lot of really interesting things have
continued going on in in discussions
about knowledge in continental
philosophy you know what what exactly
counts as science what counts as
knowledge how knowledge and hinges on
our lives think about you know people
like Michel Foucault and the will to
knowledge in them I would say some very
interesting things have happened even in
you know Thomas philosophy which is not
a you know big concern these days the
way it used to be but you know in
thinking about the nature of knowledge
itself and of course there have been
people still pushing you know historical
figures and their approaches to
knowledge I think that you know just
just as worthwhile to think about Plato
and and the questions about knowledge
today as it was 200 years ago
or 500 years ago or back in in Plato's
own time
so this is a very interesting question
by Lisa Morrison which I've somewhat
reformulated and it runs given the
situation of ever-increasing
connectedness eroding cultural and other
boundaries which philosophical concepts
would you draw the most similarities to
and I was sort of at a loss in thinking
about how it would answer this but then
after I thought about it some more
I started thinking a lot about about
Kant and also to to a you know another
extent to Hume in part because human
thought that that human nature was
something that was really uniform across
cultures deep down inside and Kant is
one of the things that kind of spins off
of him and it made me think of Humes
notion of enlightenment and of you know
it's sort of gearing towards perpetual
peace eventually between nations and
this is the sort of merest view of what
philosophy is doing and what what
critique would be doing this erosion of
difference and I myself I'm not somebody
who actually buys into that all that
much I think that when we scratch the
surface we find all sorts of differences
and all sorts of continuities between
present and past that are still living
but it we do live in a world that kind
of looks like all these these boundaries
are being eroded I actually think that
boundaries are sometimes a good thing I
don't I don't see the Faceman of you
know vital difference is always a
success I see it as sometimes a just an
imposition of one way of looking at
things one mindset particularly the
Enlightenment mindset which tends to be
very tone-deaf to anything individual
anything particular so I don't see that
as such a great thing I guess you know
since I have to wrap this up I would say
that that Kierkegaard would be somebody
who makes me think of as well
so this is a question more about the
philosophy of human nature or about
social political philosophy this from
latina-esque I know and I apologize if I
mispronounce your name do you think that
the idea of humans as being social
animals is ready for retirement and
she's referring to a short blog piece
which you can see the link to on the the
question video no I I don't think so and
I think that the blog piece is actually
not particularly good because there's I
think there's two basic mistakes that I
see getting made in a lot of places one
is of thinking about social animals
which by the way is something that's
coming from Aristotle who's a
philosopher of development thinking of
humans as being social animals does not
mean that we all possess exactly the
same battery of capacities across the
board or that those capacities are what
we're actually observing what we're what
we're talking about when we look at real
people in real social contexts and real
relationships and and take them out of
those and have them respond to each
other are not capacities they're what
they've actually developed and that's
going to be two different levels this is
why science social science is not
particularly good for analyzing these
these sorts of things the other thing
that I saw him talking about in there is
you know and there he what he's saying
would actually just reinforce what what
Aristotle and other people were saying
is you know this focus on one's own
particular group that's what Aristotle
means by social animals he doesn't mean
that you can take a whole bunch of
people from God knows where and then
throw them together and some survivor
like you know existence and they're all
gonna suddenly get along because we're
all social animals being social animals
means we can get into conflict over
things as well and it means that we tend
to glom onto those who are like us who
do share cultural things in common with
each other so our is that you know a
useless concept or something that's
going to go away
think so at all
so this is a question from Devo Ovid and
it's it's I'm boiling it down a little
bit he's referring to the video in which
I said that I'm not a Cartesian duelist
because I was talking about Descartes
but I'm more Aristotelian in thinking
that the soul is you know fused with our
body Dickert by the way did - we call
that the union in the body and soul and
he thought it was very mysterious does
that mean that you don't believe in the
immortality of the soul you know no more
than Thomas Aquinas didn't believe in
the immortality the soul Thomas Aquinas
was an Aristotelian and he thought that
the Aristotelian account made quite a
bit of sense the body or the form of the
soul is the form of the body but it can
exist independently of the body he
thought that Aristotle was was you know
often thinking that when the body is
it's undone that there's no more soul so
I would say that you know when it comes
to this sort of thing I'm more like
Aristotle what I was talking about is
this notion that the the soul and the
body are like totally totally separate
things that there's you know it's almost
purely coincidental connection between
them which is one way in which people
often interpret Descartes and Descartes
you know gives gives a lot of reason to
think that you know if you look at
Christian discussions of this in
Christian metaphysics you know the
resurrection of the person is the
resurrection of the body it's not just
the you know
Riaan flushing of the soul or something
like that there's something about our
particularity with the bodies that we
have that it that is held to be key to
be central we are our bodies as well as
being our soul if you're a Cartesian you
are your soul and you just happen to
have a body and you move around and it's
sort of like you know somebody in one of
these giant mecha things
so this is a question coming from mark
Schmitt as one I had to sort of parse
out a little bit is there a rational
defense for the concept of negation in
operatic theology could you argue for
its importance beyond merely referring
to reasons insufficiency so first I have
to give a can a proviso here I'm not a
theologian I'm a a philosopher and a
historian of ideas and I am also not
somebody who is particularly drawn to
apophatic theology for those of you
don't know what operatic theology means
is it's often called negative theology
because you you say what God isn't
rather than what God is and it's not
completely negative in the hands of all
of its practitioners but it tends to be
you know saying God is is you know
beyond this or that predicate so
therefore you know we negate that that
predicate so I'm not I'm not somebody
who's particularly into that that sort
of things so I'm talking as more of a
outsider is there a rational defense for
the concept of negation I think of your
into operatic theology you don't worry
about defense because that that's I
don't know that that that seems to be a
strange way of going about it if you're
doing Apple photic theology it's it's
oftentimes very experiential you see
what happens when you actually start
thinking about this sort of stuff and
it's necessarily experiential and that
contemplative work as far as I
understand it is an integral part of
that it's not something like you would
defend a set of propositions maybe they
do that in philosophy of religion in
some some discourses but I'm you know
that's not something that I'm really
paying much attention to could you argue
for its importance beyond merely
referring to reasons insufficiency it
seems to me that if you're doing that
sort of thing reasons insufficiency is
is quite enough that you know there's
questions there about using reason to
demonstrate reasons and sufficiency but
that doesn't strike me as that big of a
problem
so another question by marks met and
this one a little bit closer to my my
areas where I'm very competent then how
does emanation as discussed by
neoplatonist and early church fathers
such as pseudo Dionysus occur so there's
a whole bunch of different answers to
this basically that the notion of
emanation if we want to look at it in
its most generic form would be something
like this you've got a God or the one
pick whatever it is that you like to
call it and it is really beyond any sort
of determinations of being and Plato's
form of the good you know it would fit
in here as well and it by its very
nature it overflows or emanates into
another order which is lower than it and
thereby creates that and then that can
sort of you know in its turn do the same
thing and eventually you get down to the
level of you know non-being or matter or
you know what have you and it got used
in different ways by different thinkers
I'm not aware of too many church fathers
that are using it in a very in a neo
platonic sense where it's like pseudo
DMSO sore like what you know people like
like Platonists are doing with it
because for the early church fathers God
is a creator and and Christ is the logos
through which he is creating so there's
more determinacy there I would say add
to it the fact that a lot of the
Gnostics you know they used notions of
emanation as well to try to account for
how you get evil and crazy things coming
out of the Godhead and there's not that
much they're pseudo Dionysus I'm already
out of time there it's tied in with
these these hierarchies but that's about
all I can say because you know you're
asking me about something that doesn't
really fit into two minutes
all